um
you just tweeted something uh the other
day uh was it yesterday about
all the records that you and travis have
together yeah
and like what which was that which which
was everyone's favorite
you and travis uh i'm assuming there's
gonna be more music in the future
did you guys originally link up in the
good music days like back
back then because i know he was around
in that era
we linked before he even got wit or met
kanye like he was [ __ ] with
kell hoffer kill off was mixing my first
song
that ever dropped which was jay-z
interview my first rap joint
official rap joint
he came to my session and i was just
like um
we just chopped it it wasn't too much
but like when we finally
linked i just was like man this kid is
[ __ ]
he got it like i just saw the visuals i
saw the sounds he was using like
just the way he was approaching it i was
like he a real artist like he gonna be
straight in this [ __ ] for sure
and you know for him to take it to this
level man and it's like you know
we i mean bro you see that lineup
you know what i'm saying come on bro you
guys got classics bro
which part of sycomo did you do i did
the first part
before like before it cuts into travis's
part okay
i wasn't did you ever when you when you
i'm assuming you never heard saiha's
version of sicko mode
until everyone else heard it yeah i
don't think i still even heard it
oh yeah did the travis party man scott
has a [ __ ] goat by the way shout out
to
the show man you know that's more good
music you and travis got any others
i know he's working any are you are you
uh
you know hey man i'm just working bro
i ain't i can't put nothing out there
but
you know i [ __ ] with bro